hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the date almost anything
simulator if you have anything out in
the world that you would want to date
today's your lucky day because I'm going
to show you how to date literally almost
anything in the entire world maybe I
don't know
I hate quotations tell me what you know
Ralph W Emerson ah how ironic
oh I barely made it in time for my first
day of work now where is my nametag can
I make that faster that way to make that
faster no no okay all right my name tag
my name is Marky oh my name is blah my
name is my name is what my name is boo
ah mister hm
so lonely yes that's me mister mister
miscellany Oh God
ah gosh it starting from today I'll be a
barista at Starbucks coffee
hey mr. Murphy what's up ready to make
some coffee
Gracie and I have been best friends
since grade school
thanks to her support and encouragement
I was able to get this job still nervous
relax you'll do great when a customer
orders a drink all you have to do is
follow the recipe here let's practice
make me a tall hot chocolate oh honey
I'm making chocolate chocolate oh all
right then
ha ha Josh Lee seems I don't know
wait what for the flush I [ __ ] it up
sweet let's see how you did hmm you
really [ __ ] up on this one I shouldn't
hired my best friend cuz they don't know
how to know I'm not gonna lie mr.
Maloney but this isn't what I thought
Jacqueline should be I think you've done
something wrong when you put in the
ingredient also you shouldn't have tried
in the third place well practice makes
perfect right I guess here comes our
first customer
hi welcome to stir box what can I get
for you I would like a regular black
coffee no sugar or cream cringing
certainly what size would you like Paul
grande or venti
why do you come yy-you kill gobby I'm
guessing you like small medium large
this is really special here to me coffee
at home um I would like large your order
your veggie delete cool that be all
yeah that'll be three sixty-five week
holy cow so expensive you're gonna make
my own house is it
thank you very much may I have your name
it's Sheldon thank you we will call you
when your order is ready all right okay
mr. booth Salone go for it
one venti black coffee all right ah
Venki dark roast none and none got it
done already
oh hell yeah Sheldon your drink is ready
here you go one venti black coffee no
cream sugar or milk mmm that'd be add
thank you
Wow mr. mee Saloni great work cause it
made me laugh every time on to the next
customer hi welcome to stir box what can
I do for you today oh good morning miss
lovely day isn't it sure is are you
ready to order
I am a grande cappuccino would be
wonderful
okay that's one Granick haven't you know
of a be all yes ma'am for Voivod Lee oh
yeah I only have at and neck please keep
the change WIC wonk okay that's very
generous of you but don't worry about it
I'm
very wealthy pocket change quite
burdensome carry um thank you may I have
your name
Jane pleasure to meet you place same you
sir
we'll call you in you drink is ready I'm
mister me slow tea
hey it rhymes with baloney you want to
eat me huh
that'd be cool right yeah I know you do
I know you do everybody does
I got beating them off with a stick
don't know how to use my hands anyway
gosh what a nice man
it still feels kind of bad about taking
his money though I mean so just a
business or anything anyway enough
talking mr. Sulu me get a grande
cappuccino
all right espresso steamed milk foam
milk got it Grande's Fresno CA milk foam
milk got it
awesome you're getting better already
Jane your drink is ready here you go
one grande cappuccino thank you very
much it tastes wonderful please thank
the other cuter barista for me as well
Thanks the names B Salone rhymes with
Bologna I don't know if I mention that
I'm sorry all right
Wow miss cookie sure me Salone looks
like you're getting the hang of it on to
the next customer for some reason it's a
ding dong I don't know why
plug him to stir box what can I get for
you today oh there are so many to list
rate to choose from
I know where to start oh yeah no rush
sure I'll take your order when you're
ready may I have a tall latte please
okay that's one tall latte anything else
Wow kicks hey sue you rather don't have
the money for it no that's me Oh pl
that'll be 395 may I have your name ah
I go by semi I go by baloney you can
call me that if you want snick name I
made up names meets the lonely little
kids you cared about that I bet you
don't all right I'm gonna make you drink
if you didn't know me Salone Bologna
over here
all right wait how sneaky you you know
the drill once all latte Hey
if there's one thing Mesa Loney knows
how to do to make coffee doesn't rhyme
with me I didn't look that shoulda paid
attention to that one mmm gonna mess
this up what is it latte this e milk
none I got it here you go once all latte
uh-huh mr. mee Salone he didn't seem
very happy with his drink
well they'll call me Bologna for nothing
yeah you get it no all right okay be
careful next time it's thick right sighs
ingredient took a na to the next
customer you're doing great ah no one
ever told me that saved my life yeah
there was this bike parents called the
daughter mr. mee Salone yeah it's been
downhill ever said you know hey grace
thanked me for my help she says it was
nice knowing that I'm got her back
I've got her front too you know all
sides I don't discriminate he advised me
to take a break and look around the
place yeah my box they look got walls
cool never had those before where'd he
go
hey yeah go the bathroom be Saloni
baloneys gotta drain the main vein I'm a
girl
anyway I turn left down the hall seventh
side of women's room wash your hand all
employees I'm a rebel
I very never Tommy hygiene I don't even
understand that but you're not gonna
wash your hands is gross you sure about
this washing your hands after going to
the bathroom is good habit have for any
coli Salmonella and more oh you know
weird voice in my head that gives me
advice and questions my decisions meet
Salone baloney just enough [ __ ] from
everybody else in the world
I didn't take [ __ ] from you - how much
you go shove your hygienic e.coli off
your ass where it belongs
what nothing to say
I'm good then disgusting suit yourself
that's what it calls amis aloni baloney
also it call me disgusting but again
that doesn't rhyme so I don't use it as
a nickname felony kind of the slant
rhyme haven't done one of those yes baby
I know what do you know
wink want anyway going back to work now
before I know it the Sun is setting
signaling the end of my shift
okay sir two weeks we sure to bud I go
older I don't have any ambitions after
that kind of worked there for years and
died alone me baloney a lonely or anyway
everything is same yet never changing
the world does not sit still for a
nameless girl I once again I have a name
I have a lot of bad nicknames the dirt
pile hit by truck fates person smells
real bad girl that's not a creative one
but true damn I stand down babes pass
people go boys Domingo like milking sure
is your mouth together like coffee and
cream what's your bet wetting you better
mom I think I was devastated
someone can wait what
[Applause]
you guys Eisen you are an [ __ ] all
right meet Salone Bologna this is what
I'm talking about people can't just do
this to me coming out so I get it
but till dies the whole life first
birthday I ever remember oh you're not
old congratulations all right I just
made it my own you know we couldn't
touch probably here because you did
something really bad like not washing
your hands not only is it's gross spread
sugar
good job helping people dive as it I
don't rob anything that is good you're
being an absolute jerk is three hours of
suffocation we're just writing the
matrix form
oh god no matrix method before is
actually my hell is will think of this
if this is just algebra matrix no that's
just no way a matrix of philosophy no
this is algebra and there's a reminder
of unknowns here we don't have two
unknowns well make that X extra extra
bold the linear equations are ax equal B
idea now better solve this progress
angle and then I'm a cracking do I need
to wash my hand for algebra because
that's a line in the sand I will not
cross this example I don't stand for a
lot like they're riding I'm on the other
side of the fence there's like the
people like the 99.9% germ killers and
then there's me going here yeah take it
dan wait Dagestan and I won't wash my
hand him brother on a plot for that
higher two points in seven right then
what is he calling for better often it's
so the point it's zero the point with
coordinates 0 0 I got it ok anyway
that's good well that didn't go so well
yeah yeah actually try that again let me
just skip all right missile only not
doing so bad I get to take my break
all right we're here I go ok
I still stand on the hygiene front not
gonna take that I'm gonna go outside
rolling the dirt that's with me sir
means alone you gonna do that in such a
hurry to get to work I did get a good
look outside and have it go away to the
fresh air feel great after spitting
yards inside the small stuff is job
the streets are beautiful but occasional
pedestrians milling about the
storefronts all right um I'm gonna look
around some more
I wonder what's on the other side of the
girder ash caught off guard
I drink on my own foot and tumble
forward I'm a gymnast then you know took
one class fails but now you get the
diploma anyway participation words and
all but he catches my arm and lowers me
on you a graceful bit oh no I'm so sorry
ma'am
oh you all right yeah thank you let's
meet literally god I don't even know how
it happened now I was born with to write
how I got to do left I don't know all
right you know watch where I was going
how embarrassing with me I'm just a shot
with you tell you this is gonna pretend
he didn't get me in front of all these
people
I don't mind a good dipping I like
getting dipped as much as the next girl
but I know it's not the Bologna way does
he do this on a regular basis
say you look rather familiar he was a
barista who made my coffee me there's
absolute baloney in it half nah that's
about it Ben I didn't put myself in
there without up I see it a destined
reunion I'm putting my memory fails what
is your name again me Salone rhymes with
bologna you're never gonna forget it
after Rafa was my name again say it it's
baloney
no it's miss it's mister me Salone my
parents named its died on us likewise
miss to me Saloni
say do you believe in fate
god no if I did what's my purpose in
life good [ __ ] why what do you say this
guy's deal
it's like he's dipping me now blabbering
about fate I mean can't he just stick to
the dipping it was pretty good at that
the best tip I ever had
sorry don't know no worries I understand
sometimes my thoughts are like happiness
intangible fleeting oh how I pontificate
do you believe it will last forever but
it is always gone too soon like a lover
the train station the most romantic
station possible no dear I'm going off
on a tangent on tag apologies mr. me
Saloni okay
hey don't talk to me about tangents I
took a three-hour course on tangents I
know a lot about the zero zero actual
axis rise anything yes I should head
back inside casually I break ins and I
continue working behind the counter
where I know it days over
Dave during the week same place same
emotions everything's jammed well not
stiff for a nameless girl their
mysteries love and if it's bad people
girls voice mingle like melting bit
deeper but nothing quite the same except
one constant good have to move the åland
susan has become a regular cup coffee
out he usually comes here every Saturday
during the break we hang out in chat
however lately he hasn't been coming in
here's the first time I've seen him in
three weeks
hey bloody brothers I'm a girl so kind
of like Bologna brother sister but now
whatever who cares I apologize for my
absence in the past two weeks
did you miss me ah maybe a little I got
no one else in my life literally I was
talking to a tree the other day who's
dead
yeah I'm trying to encourage it to get
back to life but it didn't work I got
sad whatever Louise and I was busy
publishing my second book we won on
commodification and idealization of love
in mainstream media that immense love
back right upon and finished early this
week
Wow weaning I don't even know what a
book here's that I just made coffee I
can barely read the menu like I learned
I know like almost all the odds of it
though I'll get a copy thank you
it would be available both online and in
stores even though people rarely go to
work so I've met I am awful with
deadlines though I'd stare through the
night to finish on time
oh well like the saying goes nothing is
strong cup of coffee convicts ha ha
I get it don't worry I get it I'm a
coffee that's why it's funny right I'm a
coffee er that that's why you me anyway
the tenacity of a human compete with
never cease lazily so mr. Meeks alertly
how's life been treating you anything
else you mind lately
ah same gonna come out right and say it
somehow I ask you well as [ __ ] you
haven't you been dipping me anymore baby
come on you dip me once and then just
leave me hanging
please ask away no guarantee I'll be
able to answer them I like you a lot
yeah you got good Nick sound oh thank
you dear the same to you you have proved
the best nips I've ever seen
will you be my
different oh my
you think what did save all isn't it is
confession you little is everything when
you put so plainly I like it
mister mix ellonija oh wait hold it
right there stop right there criminal
scum you can't ask him out you barely
even know him this isn't supposed to be
a realistic game like God it makes no
sense because you made him copy and I
don't like ones he's authorized a to you
now buddy gotta earn it how did you get
to this part of the game you took
initiative got options run to go in
circle it to be a bad person but you
didn't you persevered it the video game
though you can do the right thing with
the kick of the button that made a mile
a pretty easy B's you don't even have to
think about it shame your life didn't
work that way reals that Bobby Richard
babies not add my ass coding a dating
simulator I mean you're part of the
sitting there with your mouth open
sharing theater hey you're not Calvin
Street alone you want me to meet alone
he does with his or her mouth mister
mean Loney's mouths is off-limits to you
wasting your time in a game called date
almost anything simulator for Christ's
sake which is almost as pathetic as the
dumbass who decided to make it hey
there's one thing that rhymes with me
through me soluti a besides baloney its
dumbass so you have something better to
do nah do you work this is my work
finish your chores literally this is
what I'm supposed to do clean my room as
far as everybody knows it's clean but
down here it's a swamp like Shrek's
right in the corner and you never knew
better yet when was last time you
started conversation with a stranger
made someone coffee take initiative in
your own life not just a video game
do something anything eat food drink
some water take a walk by the next
person in line of coffee
hell if you're really lazy tell me about
your day your mysteries loading you got
four days about how my day is yeah I'm
not going to do that yeah I am
do that one click away am i right you
downloaded the game thing it was going
to be funny here's a real funny joke for
you it's just my face
usually the punchline in these things oh
I get it
oh [ __ ] you're done all that work to
give the end name see the ending what
awaits describe which is exactly what
I'm doing right now see I'm just going
in the game here one big bill up to
goddamn nothing and yeah lately you're
hanging this again you seem disappointed
frustrated no I'm mr. meets alone he's
been living with deeds applause
disappointment her whole life that's not
really a new sensation trade ya know so
oval cuz you keep clicking that left
mouth I'm actually Haven spacebar don't
know if you know that's more efficient
for me come on Blaine get mad rage quit
I'll play this game again
close this window delete the file turn
off your computer and finish whatever
you were doing before probably never
want to come back after what I just
pulled I'm glad too because I want you
to leave this game and never come back
but before you go one last thing they
love you these are his words my words
whatever you decide to do after
finishing this game we'll be there for
you in spirit I mean I get it doing
things is hard living is hard too many
distractions
too many pitfalls too many things to do
be vain and I are still proud of you for
making it this far in life just like
we're proud of you for making it this
far in the game does our breakup letter
to time-wasters instant gratification
and procrastination this is our love
letter to you know God and change the
world
love
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] that hit me right in my
feelers mr. nice Elodie's below Deus
rumblin created by sky cue storyline by
me me me me me me me me me me hey we did
it
we dated Zayn and we got you an ending
besides the [ __ ] ending I feel like a
changed person here that's actually kind
of cool so I imagine there's actually a
lot of endings like a lot of different
things that you can do through here I'm
not gonna get to all of them but I
actually gotta find this game charming
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this down the comments below I had a lot
of fun with this because I was just
having fun on my own with mr. me Salone
you guys witnessed the birth of a brand
new character that I hope to never bring
back ever again so let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
I'll put a link in the description I
believe this game is totally free so you
guys can check out the other endings for
yourself or maybe I'll play another one
try to write I try to get to the recipe
and eggs in another episode clip let me
know what you think down the comments
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]